not long until this crucial vote it
looks as if Theresa May will lose it so
what's plan B
well let's cross that bridge when and if
it happens right now her focus might
focus the government's focus is on
convincing people that actually this is
the best thing to do it's the right
option it's the most likely to deliver
brexit and we want to convince
colleagues that it's the right thing to
do to back it and I understand that you
know you want to focus on the vote ahead
but people are quite worried I'm gonna
spend a week in Harlow for example where
people are really concerned about what
happens next if the deal falters so
let's make a deal just tell me what plan
B is but you have got one right well
look the important thing right now is to
convince people otherwise I mean I'm not
going to get into would we do this where
we do that where we do the other the
important thing is to say to fellow MPs
if those concerns are out there and
there's big concerns are we going to
leave are we going to deliver brexit are
we going to somehow try and reverse
brexit is Parliament going to focus us
to reverse brexit what we have is I
think a sensible compromise deal it's
not giving everybody everything they
want but it was never going to this was
a 52-48 result have you got everything
you want of course not
and I did I think most people the Prime
Minister has sent herself a said this is
not the perfect deal but if he'd offered
me this deal back in 2016 at the time of
the referendum you said instead of
staying in the European Union you can
have this I'd have said thank you very
much at the same time though I
understand you don't want to get into
the details but if you don't say what
your plan B it's or at least give the
implication that you have a plan B then
other people will step into that gap and
the Sunday papers are absolutely full of
MPs from different parties coming up
with their own plan B stepping into the
void that's been left by your government
well if the heart I think it is a voice
at all the government's coming forward
with a proposal to the nation a proposal
to Parliament says this is what we think
is the best compromise deal and they
will just leave us good friends good
neighbors on good terms with the
European Union and carry on trading with
the European Union and at the same time
get the benefits of brexit hoping to
forge our own trade policies to leave
the the single market legislation to
leave the the the customs union to leave
the common agricultural policy to leave
the corner Fisheries Policy what we
campaign for in 2016 was not to become
an inward focused nation not to walk
away from
International friendships it was to stay
good friends and neighbors to be a
globally focused country but actually
take back control of our laws and our
finances and I think that this deal
achieves that but it does so in a way
that recognizes the fact the nation is
pretty divided on this issue I mean more
than a half of MPs have publicly said
that they are not going to be backing
the deal so the prospect of No Deal
becomes very real you of course have
been very involved in some of that No
Deal planning as transport secretary
just wanted to really talk for a while
about how that modal planning is going
because for example you've employed a
company called Seaborn Freight to
provide some extra ferry boots it's now
emerged that they don't have any ships
and actually they won't be ready until a
month after we've left I mean that's not
going to spark confidence in people is
it well what I've done is I've hired two
very well-established ferry companies
DFDS and Brittany Ferries
to supply an element of extra capacity
across the channel in an ideal scenario
first and foremost our goal and my prime
priority there No Deal scenario is to
keep the conventional route through
Dover and Calais and through the Channel
Tunnel moving smoothly I've had
conversations my French counterpart
we've had political discussions with the
French we've had all official
discussions with the French and everyone
is committed to keeping things flowing
as smoothly as possible so that's why
we're putting in place some extra
capacity to take some of the pressure
off the system now we have a smaller
third business that came along and said
we can do something for you to a very
small proportion of what we need we have
given the opportunity to do that they
don't get paid unless they deliver the
service but I'm not in the business of
saying to a new British company you
can't take part what I'm the business of
doing is saying is if you want to take
part you have to prove you can deliver
and we're not going to pay you until you
do another thing that perhaps isn't
going to be inspiring a huge amounts of
confidence is the traffic jam that we're
so organised in which 150 lorries were
hoped to turn up and actually only 89
actually arrived I mean we can't even
organize a traffic jam so embarrassing
isn't it well that because that wasn't
the perfect size it's great to grab
these headlines and so it didn't work
actually what we were doing was tracking
the flows of lorries in and out of
Menston airfield and further down on the
a 256
actually in groups of 25 so you could
see how quickly
lorries can move into and out of the
side
people tend to look at something form
your own impressions and reach
conclusion over what's happening
actually the trial worked fine and if
you are bringing in lawyers on the day
and something will get late work to do
you inviting more than you needs to get
the job done and that's what we did have
you been in touch with the Ministry of
Defense about and some of your nodal
planning I've talked to Gavin Williamson
about No Deal planning quite regularly
yes what what about well when we discuss
as cabinet colleagues what we would do
in No Deal planning terms and when I
don't have the military actively
involved in No Deal planning beyond the
seconds of a small number of staff from
the Ministry of Defence as is happening
across Whitehall and when our focus in
No Deal planning has been to make sure
we have all the aviation agreements we
need in place making sure that we take
into account the possibility of
disruption in Kent I do not want to
repeat of what happened in 2015 when the
whole of Kent was granted halt by
troubles in the the Channel ports making
sure that we have some alternative
capacity in place if it's needed but
first and foremost working with the
French working with people that you're a
tunnel working with people at Dover and
Calais to make sure that we keep the
trade flowing smoothly everybody wants
that to happen if the Army is on standby
the military the military is ready to
help if it looks like there will be
major disruption well no I have not
asked for military support for the
operations in Kent that will be handled
by how is England and by Kent Police
okay now yesterday you said that the far
right could benefit if brexit isn't
pushed through I just want to have a
little look at some of those comments
that and you did make because she said
that if mp's don't back Therese Mays
deal we risk a break with the British
tradition of moderate mainstream
politics that goes back to the
restoration in 1660 what did you mean
well I think you're putting into quotes
things I didn't actually say as a quote
but what I actually meant was that if we
do now we miss quoted that I think that
was a quote outside question marks I've
ever called mentioning the restoration
what I said is we will lose a tradition
my understanding is that was in
quotation marks okay let me explain my
concern is that we will have in the
aftermath of a decision not to go ahead
with brexit if we do not fulfill the
terms of that referendum
what we will have
it is the arrival in this country of the
kind of populist politics on the
extremes that we're seeing in most other
European countries we have always in
this country and this is where the point
is actually right we have always had I
think a sensible political mainstream
that has dealt with issues in a mature
way throughout the decades but what we
haven't seen in this country is the
appearance of political extremism in the
way that we have seen in some other
countries over the years I do not want
that the emergence of the populist
parties that we're seeing in most other
European countries now in this country
because we've turned around to the
people to the seventeen point four
million people who voted to leave and
simply said to them what guys sorry
we're not leaving after all so just to
be clear because in the melon thunder on
the male interview and they were saying
that and that you're talking about the
breaking with the tradition of politics
it goes back to the restoration in 1660
and I think what some people are
thinking is hang on there's been a lot
of pretty bad things and have happens in
1660 Wars executions millions of people
not be able to vote at all they were the
good old days know that I did not
specifically mention the date 1660 what
I said is that I'm concerned that we
will see now the kind of populist
politics in this country that we have
previously seen emerging other European
countries I do not want that to happen
okay now I just want to talk about your
own record because she'd been transport
secretary now for two and a half years
train punctuality is at a 13-year low
but Affairs keep rising more than three
thousand bus routes reduced or scrapped
since 2010 is it a record that you're
proud of and do you think things are
better now well I think what we're
dealing with on the railways is
continually expanded demand for services
our rail network is absolutely full we
are putting a huge amount of money into
the rail network 47 billion pounds over
the next five years opening new services
around the country starting new routes
replacing old trains with new one every
single train in the north of England is
being replaced with a brand new or a
completely refurbished train over the
coming months we've got new Express
trains on the East Coast Main Line on
the Great Western Main Line on the
transparent coming later this year a
huge amount of investment taking place
around the country some of that
investment has been delayed
frustratingly so what happened with
Northern Rail last summer because of the
delay to do that for
of the line from Blackpool to Manchester
that was an investment programme that we
were putting in the government funding
which was delay then caused knock-on
effects to the timetable so the reason
we are spending this money is because we
recognize that the rail system is hugely
congested and what we're trying to do is
to ease the pressure increased capacity
give people a better travelling
experience I said I can't help but
thinking that if you are one of these
rail passengers you know we've been to
Wigan with the Shay for example spoken
to some of these people who've been
their lives really really put under
great strain because of the delays not
being able to get back to put their kids
to bed struggling to get to interviews
into jobs because they just can't rely
on the transport set system and the
answer it's not gonna be good enough is
it
well that's so of course it's not good
enough Furman this is why we're
replacing all the trains for those
people with brand-new trains and more
seats with more capacity and the
frustration last summer was the problems
were caused by an electric asian project
that went wrong that was delay this was
government investment that was delayed
it wasn't government not putting in
money it was governed investing money
and a delay to the project which meant
there was a knock-on effect the electric
trains couldn't be used and therefore
that there was a shortage of rolling
stock it was hugely frustrating it's why
we issue have made made sure that
passengers will receive compensation for
what happened the service is now running
better it's not perfect that's a way to
go yet but the service is running better
and more reliably now but it's not
nearly good enough yet and that's why I
think the new trains coming across the
north over the next few months will make
a real difference and we didn't mention
and bus routes there which I did in my
original question and I can't help
thinking again bus routes are something
that people don't give enough attention
to in Westminster and yet you know
disproportionately people are no incomes
tend to use buses and people outside of
our southeast I mean do you use the best
I do occasionally I use the Train mostly
I catch the train most days I use the
bus from time to time but this is one
reason why we've given them franchising
powers back to marilyn recognition that
it may be necessary for them to plan a
significantly integrated network better
services and I've seen places where
local authorities are really working
with the private operators to deliver
better services like Cornwall for
example you're seeing a rising ridership
you're seeing a rise in revenues and a
better service for passengers so it can
be done
and I just want to talk about drones as
well before we leave because I have to
say it's been pretty embarrassing
husband and two of our major airports
they're temporarily shut down because of
drones and there's been a lot of
questions about why this wasn't
recognized sooner as an issue well a
simple answer is that in a case of
Gatwick what happened there was a unique
situation that's not happened anywhere
else in the world
Heathrow was different Heathrow it was a
drone that appeared and disappeared some
people that was rotating was a
deliberate disruptive attack the systems
do not exist to completely tackle a
problem like this we were able to bring
in some military equipment that helped
ease the situation Gatwick is now
looking to put together a new set of
systems you can tackle the problem but
we've had airports from all around the
world come to us since this happened and
said we're not sure how we would cope
how did you cope this is a new area the
technology is very immature there's a
lot of effort now going into this from
airports around the UK we're working
with them to try and find the right
solutions but there wasn't a simple
off-the-shelf solution that should have
been in place that wasn't in place it
feels as if you've been trailed so it's
like mr. misfortune in the Department of
Transport with the drones before that in
the Ministry of Justice with a very
controversial cuts to legal aid with
their issues with the Probation Service
why do you think it is that this kind of
misfortunes are following you well it's
a challenging time for all of us in
government we have to deliver change we
have to tackle new issues like the
drones for example so it's a question of
getting on with the job and tackling the
problems at best you can but the end of
the day dealing with your financial
positions and also dealing with
particular challenges like the expanding
demand on the railways you just get
again on with the job and do your best
okay thank you very much you're welcome